نتوقف مع هذه الصور التي وصلتنا مشاهدينا
قبل قليل والتي تظهر القائد العام للقوات
المسلحه
السودانيه الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني وهو في جوله
لتفقد جنود القوات المسلحه السودانيه في
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم اذا ظهور جديد
لقائد الجيش السوداني الفريق اول عبد
الفتاح
البرهان في جوله بين قواته جوله تفقديه
لجنود القوات المسلحه السودانيه في
العاصمه الخرطوم والتي تشهد ازمه سودانيه
سودانيه بين الجيش السوداني
وقوات الدعم السريع والتي اندلعت شراره
هذه الازمه منذ اكثر من شهر في السودان
كما تابعنا واياكم خلال الاسابيع الماضيه
وهذه صور اخرى
طبعا
اوليدات الظهور الجديد لقائد الجيش
السوداني الفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان
اذا من العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم كما
نشاهد في هذه الصور اذا هذا الظهور للفريق
اول عبد الفتاح البرهان قائد
القائد العام للقوات المسلحه طبعا كما
يظهر في هذه الصور بانه بالقرب طبعا من
مقر قياده طبعا القوات البريه قياده
القوات البريه السودانيه كما نشاهد في هذه
اللافته خلف البرهان في الحرس الرئيسي كما
نشاهد بالقرب طبعا من مطار العاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم كنا نتابع واياكم خلال
الاسابيع الماضيه هذه المعارك السودانيه
السودانيه بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
والتي تركزت بالقرب من المطار وبالقرب من
قياده القياده العامه للقوات المسلحه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات